bio conference live session
so my name's howard morris and
i'm i have a joint appointment with the
university of south australia and the uh
essay pathology which is the major sound
pathology service in south australia
today's presentation i want to address
the key issues from providing a high
quality
clinical service for serum 25 hydroxy
vitamin d
i will welcome any questions that you
have
and please put enter them at the time
at any time throughout the presentation
and then i will address them at the
conclusion
so we're
talking about
so
the measurement of sound total 25
hydroxy vitamin d is essential to assess
vitamin d status
and the developments of a reference
measurement procedure and a reference
standards have improved the accuracy of
many of the rooting assays that are
available for 25 hydroxy vitamin d
amongst the experts there's general
agreement that there are benefits for
assessing vitamin d status in specific
patient groups
but population screening is discouraged
and thought to be
not cost effective
certainly
vitamin d deficiency and i emphasize
that deficiency
is associated with an increased risk of
a wide range of diseases including
metabolic bone disease cancer decreased
immune function and increased autoimmune
reactivity
however i'd like to emphasize that the
highest level of evidence is simply
limited to demonstrating that adequate
vitamin d status and dietary calcium
intakes protect against metabolic bone
disease falls and premature mortality
these data have come from randomized
controlled trials where vitamin d and
dietary calcium supplements were
provided to
the patients
and they were testing in the main that
vitamin d and calcium would protect
against fractures however these other
aspects such as falls and premature
mortality came out of such
studies
so therefore we have not established
whether dietary calcium or vitamin d
status alone has any benefit on these
outcomes
so this is the
metabolic pathway for the activation of
vitamin d and you've probably seen this
well before but the points that i want
to make is that the activation of
vitamin d
requires sequential hydroxylation steps
catalyzed by different enzymes
firstly to synthesize the pro hormone 25
hydroxy d which is inactive and in the
plasma is largely synthesized in the
liver
and then the second hydroxylation step
synthesizes 125 dihydroxy vitamin d and
in again in the plasma the 125 dihydroxy
vitamin d the hydroxylation takes place
in the kidney
and so therefore that produces
plasma 125 d which is suitable for
endocrine activity that endocrine
activity
is is exerted by entering the cells as
described in the slide
and
binding to the vitamin d receptor a
nuclear transcription factor which then
binds to chromatin in vitamin d
responsive genes and initiates
transcription of those genes
and these activities can regulate
certainly calcium homeostasis they do
affect cellular differentiation and
probably interact with the immune system
now and second
biological activity or mode of
biological activity for vitamin d
is through an autocrine
activity where the pro hormone 25 d
actually enters the cells and there it
is converted again by the enzymes 27 b1
to 125 dihydroxy vitamin d and then that
it is this
internally synthesized 125d which exerts
biological activity
so therefore the pro hormone is the
source
of both an endocrine activity through
activation in the kidney to produce
plasma 125d as well as the autocline
activity where it is enters the cells
that is converted into
125d and acts within those cells where
it's formed
now there are certainly difficulties and
complexities with assay
serum 25 hydroxy vitamin d and that is
due to a number of reasons which i'll
now
discuss first of all we are actually
working we often are working with two
different slightly different uh chemical
forms of vitamin d as shown here in
these structures vitamin d3 or
cholecalciferol which is derived from
animals and are derived particularly
from cholesterol
as well as ergocalciferol vitamin d2
which is derived from fungi and plants
and has a slightly but significantly
different structure especially for amino
acids
now
both vitamin d3 and vitamin d
ii are metabolized to the 25 hydroxy and
125 dihydroxy metabolites
only the c25 hydroxy metabolite
indicates the vitamin d status
and the usefulness of the measurement of
125 dihydroxy vitamin d
levels is limited and produ and
certainly limited to
specialists but in particular
vitamin d status is indicated by the sum
of 25 hydroxy d3 and 25 hydroxy d2
and equinola detection of each of these
metabolites is essential to report an
accurate total serum 25 hydroxy d
it's also important to recognize that
the
molecular rates of 25 hydroxy d3 and 25
hydroxy d2 are not equal there's a
significant about a three percent
difference and therefore if you're
calculating the total serum 25 hydroxy d
from adding
25 d3 as nanograms per mil and 25 d2 as
nanograms per mill you will end up with
a slight but significant error of about
three percent
they should be added in nanomoles per
liter because one nanomole of 25 d3
equals one nanomole of 25 d2
so the difficulties encountered in
measuring and providing a service for
the cereal 25 hydroxy d assays include
the following it's a highly lipophilic
molecule and therefore not necessarily
easily transferred from
the the blood levels the aqueous bases
that we use also
in blood 25 hydroxy d2 is bound tightly
to a binding protein the vitamin d
binding protein or dbp
and when we're measuring it we assume
that there is a 100 percent displacement
of the 25 d from the bbp but that is
what we assume we have no evidence
whether it's 100 in every assay or 90 in
some assets
we have all these various metabolites
that i've just described to you we had
the
hydroxy the various hydroxy metabolites
25d 125b we also had 2425
dihydroxy vitamin d and the epi 25
hydroxy d and then we might if patients
are taking d2 we might have
the two forms of those metabolites and
d3 so we have a very large number of
closely related molecularly related uh
metabolites in which we're trying to
measure just one of those
when we're trying to establish in-house
assays it's very difficult and we need
to to provide calibrators and in the
factory for ourselves in those in-house
assays we have to use calibrators in
ethanol solutions
the preparation of these standards is
difficult if you add known amounts of 25
hydroxyd to serum
then and then assay that without in an
assay which does not have an extraction
procedure then you
always get you erroneous results because
and we don't really know why but we
presume that there's inadequate
equilibrium with the vitamin d binding
protein there's an inability to extract
it properly
but it just doesn't work
and then we have other matrix
interferences and these can occur under
various clinical conditions such as
renal failure or pregnancy and i'll
discuss those specific interferences uh
more as later in this presentation
so the question then the difficulties is
well demonstrated by the variation in
performance in external quality
assurance
assays and and systems and here i'll
just spend a few couple of slides
describing the dqos data generated in i
think this is 2013 but it's the major
external quality assurance program that
clinical labs subscribe to when
providing assays for
25 hydroxy vitamin d and then you can
see that at this time there's some 1083
participants now there's a lot of assays
so let's just focus in on a few of those
essays and so these data are
demonstrating that accuracy is a problem
so with target value set at some 36.2
nanograms per mill
the various assays generated values
ranging between 32.6 to 46.2 nanograms
per mill quite a variation
as well
precision is a problem and now you can
see that the imprecision is measured as
percent coefficient of variation or
sieving percent ranges between six and
twenty percent
so these difficulties have been
certainly recognized over a period of
time and
the international community and in
particular various
organizations that took it upon
themselves to try and provide some some
relief
and this was called through establishing
the vitamin d standardization program it
was coordinated by cdc in atlanta
nist and the university of ghent in
belgium
and there they had
30 serum samples obtained from
apparently healthy single donors they
collected a significant amount of blood
and serum from each donor
they then measured the 25 hydroxy d
level using the specific
lc tandem mass spectrometric reference
method so not just any or a varied lc
msms method that the reference method
that had been uh
assessed as providing the optimal
analytical device
they then distributed these but these
serum samples across participating
laboratories to calibrate both
commercial and in-house methods as well
as all the in vitro diagnostic
immunoassays and then they distribu a
verification uh set was
conducted on four sets of ten samples in
2013.
acceptable bias was and in precision
were found and achieved through this
program with a bias of plus or minus
five percent and cv have plus or minus
now some very interesting data have been
published just uh earlier this year
including chem actor by izzy ann
cavellier from the university of liege
in belgium
and i'll present these to you he
established the lcms tandem
spectrometric
reference method in his own laboratory
and uh and and verified that it was
working uh
optimally
and then he collected some 186
uh
patient specimens from those that have
been
submitted routine for routine
assays in his laboratory
incidentally there was no 25 hydroxy d2
detected in any of these samples
so initially
and he measured these 186 also by lcms
and by five uh routine immunoassays from
the architects centaur the alexis the
isis and the diaspora and liaison
and then he related the
values obtained by lcms to each of those
to the values obtained from each of
those
commercial immunoassays and what you can
see there in that
table is the first of all the slope of
the
relationship described by the two
various assays and you can see that
basically there's a significant uh
variance from one
one is what we're after we want a one
for one relationship but for architect
there was only 89
of the values obtained by lcms for the
centaur it was uh four percent high etc
so these were significant
biases being obtained as well even the
intercepts were significantly uh varied
from zero
and then he
calibrated each of the uh commercial
immunoassays with this calibration set
and now re-assayed them and now could
obtain
values slopes between the two values are
very close to
one and therefore demonstrating that the
standardization of this this assay can
be applied to these commercial assays
and so this is very encouraging you can
see the slope is very close to one as
well the intercept is very close to zero
now he then collected specimens from
specific
patient groups which were
and then tested these as a verification
panel so the patient groups he collected
were patients with third trimester
pregnancy there were 34 of those he
collected plasma or sound from 28
patients who were undergoing
hemodialysis and 34 patients uh who
had been diagnosed with osteoporosis
and then he assayed them again on by the
email assay and lcms and compared their
results
now what i'm showing you here are the
scatter plots from both the calibration
panels for each of the assays on the
left and then the effectiveness pan
the
scatter plot on the right so first of
all let's still look at the calibration
panel and why you can see so here you
see the architect versus lcms and all
the central versus lcms
even in the calibration panel you can
see that there are patients who are
significantly different from the
line of unity um although on average the
line of unity uh or the the the
relationship the equation described uh
basically overrides and sits alongside
the line of unity so as a population
group there is very good the excellent
comparability between the two assays but
for individual patients there are
significant variances and this is an
issue which will will stick with us
providing a a clinical service and then
to my view that the
manufacturers of these immunoassays
should be able to tell us what is the
variance what is causing this variance
in some individual patients and
and therefore be able to help us
provide and improve service and of
course we should know and we should be
on the lookout for uh values which for
some reason or other we think are
not being
accurately assayed by an immunoassay
system if that's what we're using in our
laboratory
and then on the right we now he went to
the effectiveness panel with these
specific uh patient groups and now you
see that there is still significant
variation from those patient groups but
from the line of unity so the
calibration and the standardization
program has not been able to correct all
patient groups um for
in these immunoassay systems and again
i'll just show you on the next slide for
the other three systems and the sound uh
uh evidence the same interpretation is
there except perhaps for the isis where
there was uh even in the effectiveness
panel there was an achievement of uh on
average of the line of unity uh in the
in those patient groups
so what are the sources what are the
factors affecting automated immunoassays
for serum 25 hydroxyd
well
we saw that the patients with the third
trimester pregnancy were significantly
different from the ms values and they
had much higher vitamin d binding
protein levels than the other patient
groups so it would appear that vitamin d
binding protein or the variation in
vitamin d binding protein amongst
patient groups is likely to be a
significant uh component of this variant
the hemodialysis patients were also
significantly different their specimens
were uranic and as well vitamin d
metabolism is disturbed or often
disturbed
in patients with renal failure with high
probability of increased levels of the
catabolic component metabolite 2425
dihydroxy vitamin d and that metabolite
very often
cross-reacts in
immunoassay systems particularly
immunoassay systems that is you that are
using the vitamin d binding protein as
the binding protein
as well there are other issues which
still are affecting the
clinical serum 25 hydroxy d assays
one is the
serum measurement of serum 25 hydroxy d2
there the serum specimens used for the
standardization protocol largely did not
contain 25 hydroxy d2 so the standard
protocol has it hasn't been as
evaluated from measuring 25 hydroxy d2
as well
the mist uh standard reference material
which contains 25 hydroxy d2 cannot be
used in the immunoassays because there
are matrix effects that 25 hydroxy
vitamin d2 was just added to whole serum
and as i've mentioned previously this uh
does not equilibrate so 125 hydroxyd is
added to serum in vitro non-extraction
assays provide erroneous result and we
don't know the basis but presumably
because there's no equilibrium with
vitamin d binding protein
and then even in mass spectrometric
assays there is the problem of the
impossible interference from three epi
25 hydroxyd
threopy is the one hydroxyl group the
in a different conformation then that
occurs naturally
and many of the
lc msms assays
do not separate 25 hydroxyd from three
epi 25 hydroxy d and therefore um it
overestimates 25 hydroxy d
now
we don't know
the clinical role or the physiological
role of three
epi 25 hydroxy d so therefore we don't
know how to interpret their results we
don't know whether they should be
combined with the total serum 25d or
rather they do not have activity and
therefore they shouldn't be
so
higher levels are detected in young and
neonates and it's often higher when the
25 hydroxyd levels are higher
it's not apparent not measured by
immunoassays but as as noted here we do
not know whether it has a physical
physiological role and we don't know how
to interpret value these are areas of
research and investigation that are
currently underway
and then the final difficulty that we
have in interpreting 25 hydroxyd
is whether we should be
interpreting and reporting the total 25
hydroxy d
or whether we see that the uh whether we
should be reporting a free or
bioavailable um
25 hydroxy vitamin d
some
interesting data uh
from
one particular group would have been
published over the last few years since
where they found that
there was a better correlation with bone
mineral density in young healthy adults
with
the free or the bioavailable 25 hydroxy
rather than total serum 25 hydroxyd this
same group found that there was a better
correlation with mineral metabolism for
bioavailable 25 hydroxyd in hemodialysis
patients
and then they also reported that
bioavailable 25 hydroxy
vitamin d may be a more appropriate for
as a cross racial marker of vitamin d
sufficiency
however these data are controversial
with the there is there is
they have generated considerable amount
of
literature and discussion particularly
around the assay for the d binding
protein that
they use and therefore uh for those of
us who are providing a routine clinical
service for this assay it's unlikely
that we will be including it in
any time in the near future
so just to clarify the free hormone
hypothesis the 25
is a steroid pro hormone which
circulates bound to the vitamin d
binding protein and albumin there is a
number unbound fraction the so-called
free fraction and it's present at very
low levels
the bioavailable 25 hydroxy d is 25d
bound to albumin plus the free level
and power and colleagues calculated the
bioavailable 25d levels from
measurements of total 25d
measurements of the dbp and then
modified the moon equation which was
originally developed for the calculation
of bioavailable testosterone
it's certainly been recognized that
polymorphisms in the gene for dbp
provide different structures of d
binding protein and the concentration of
these struct different structures impact
on 25 hydroxy hydroxyd biological
activities when i say in vitro in
macrophages so there has been some
evidence that this is important as a
biological
determinant of activity in some systems
but certainly we don't know it in all
systems
so now i'm going to move on to the
question of interpreting 25 hydroxy d
values
every clinical
laboratory report must include reference
concentrations to enable interpretation
of the patient value
we currently use two practices
before at the various assays that we
provide from a routine laboratory
one is to provide the range for a
healthy population and so for sodium or
something or potassium we will report a
value on a patient and be able to allow
the clinician to interpret that value in
terms of the values for sodium for
health
in other metabo other assays we report
critical levels for disease so for the
reporting for instance of
prostate specific antigen we have values
that are that that are predictive that
have a higher risk of can prostate
cancer as opposed to a lower risk of
prostate cancer and and so that's a
critical level for disease
now for serum 25 hydroxyd
if we report simply a reference range
based on a healthy population
that range simply represents the uvb
exposure of the population that we chose
and that does not necessarily indicate
that they this population has
appropriate levels for health
and of course therefore our reference
ranges determine it this way they would
vary with latitude and with season and
yet we have no evidence that there's a
variation in the biological requirement
for vitamin d uh in
varying with latitude all season we
think we all need the same amount so
using that type of approach for
reporting uh a patient's serum 25
hydroxy d levels is inappropriate
however there may be one exception and
i'll just discuss that briefly
this study
was conducted and published recently
and it took the approach that humans
evolved in equatorial africa and that
that was therefore where the requirement
the biological requirement for 25
hydroxyd for our body arose and
therefore they went to equatorial africa
and collected blood from the maasai and
had zabi tribes who were still living a
traditional agricultural
lifestyle and there they found that the
values of twitch here and 25d uh were
very much higher than those which we now
encounter in clinical practice
and therefore uh if we were to derive a
reference interval from this population
saying that well this is the population
under which humanity derived um
then we would have a reference range of
something like 32 to 60 nanograms per
mil and of course that's
speculative that's that's assuming other
factors that that would be one approach
to take
however
the best approach in my view and
something that i've been pursuing over
many years some 30 years of working in
the political laboratory is to identify
critical levels of serum 25 hydroxyd
required to avoid disease
and this is a highly controversial
subject at the moment we've had recently
the institute of medicine report
suggesting that levels
greater than 20 nanograms per mill are
satisfactory and we've had other expert
panels uh presenting reports suggesting
that 30 nanograms per ml is the minimum
level required for health
now let's go through the evidence for
these uh critical levels
there is certainly general agreement
that serum 25 hydroxy d levels below
eight nanograms per mil represent severe
deficiency and the general agreement is
based on data such as those obtained
here so here you see a table of 25d
levels in nanomoles per liter then
nanograms per mil then the ionized
calcium plasma ionized calcium level in
millimoles per liter and in the far
right column there's the pth
now these data were obtained from
patients presenting to a clinic who had
all low 25 hydroxy vitamin d levels that
is they were less than um 16 nanograms
per mil
and when they were the patients they
were analyzed their data were analyzed
on the basis of varying the 25 hydroxy d
levels
you can see that as the 25 d levels
increase from
naught to four nanograms per mill there
is a very low
iona plasma ionized calcium 1.14 and a
very high pth level of 15.6 so at that
level these most of these patients have
hypocalcevia which is considered
a marked
indicator of the vitamin d deficiency
however by simply moving these patients
or their 25 d levels to slightly higher
levels say above 8
then an 8 nanograms per mil then they
achieved uh ionized calcium levels which
were
much closer to adequate 1.18 and pgh
levels much lower at 5.7 and so what we
can see is that there is a rapid at very
at levels above below eight nanomoles
per eight nanograms per mill of 25d
there is a very high uh probability that
patients will
demonstrate hypocalcemia
and further data like this are shown
in a study
published from
indian colleagues from new delhi
and here they had patients young women
presenting with what they just diagnosed
as biochemical osteomalacia
and this was done on a number of
criteria and the mean value for the
patients the mean serum 25 d value for
these patients was around about 14 uh
nano moles per liter so around about
five to six nanograms per mil
and their pth level was quite high at 26
picomoles per liter
now these
researchers also collected blood from
the
sisters and brothers and mothers and
fathers of these patients
and they found and they assessed them
for biochemical osteomalacia and they
found that by
simply when the 25 hydroxy vitamin d
level rose from about 5.8 nanograms per
mill to about 7.3 nanograms per ml
that's with the sisters
that the incidence of biochemical
osteomalacia was decreased by some 75
and that by raising the serum 25d levels
just a little further up to 30 nano
nanomoles per liter then the incidence
of biochemical osteomalacia again
decreased even further so therefore
we're saying that these data are
consistent that
osteomalacia at the level of and there
are other data on
on biopsies of bone which is the
definition of osteomyelation the
diagnosis is really depends on that
that osteomalacia is resolved at levels
of around about eight nanograms per mill
of 25 hydroxy vitamin d
so therefore
we have this general agreement that
less than 8 really represent severe
deficiency
however there's also been generated over
the last uh
30 years
that
recognition that the risk of
osteoporotic fractures increases with
serum 25 hydroxyd levels below 20
nanograms per mil
and again we have a large amount of data
so here you see a forest plot of cats
control studies and conducted over many
years the first one from 1970 which
doesn't show an effect
and possibly in 1970
the colleagues the researchers could not
really measure 25 hydroxyd at that time
but each since that time uh every other
study has demonstrated that the patients
with fractures uh have lower 25 hydroxyd
levels than their controls with age
match controls who don't have fractures
now
to look at the actual level here are
data from a couple of recent papers one
from the journal of clinical
endocrinology and metabolism in 2009
and there they found that the rate of
bone loss in older community dwelling
men was significantly less when the
serum 25 d levels were between 20 and 30
nanograms per mill compared to
uh
the men whose levels of 25 d were
between 15 and 20 nanograms per mil
so by just simply moving above 20 here
we have a critical level of 20 nanograms
per ml for 25d determining the rate of
bone loss
in post-menopausal women in a study
published in
the
risk of fracture was markedly increased
when the serum 25d level was less than
19 nanograms per mill compared to women
with a serum 25d level of around about
29 nanograms per ml so here again we see
this this level at around about 20
nanograms per mil where there is a
change in the risk of osteoporotic
fracture
and of course those studies are sort of
just association studies and they can
only be demonstrated the the causal
relationship between 25 hydroxy d and
risk of hip fracture can only be
demonstrated by randomized controlled
trials and these fracture studies have
been conducted and here you see forest
plots for randomized controlled trials
conducted for hip fracture and other
non-invertible fractures on the right
and only when the 25 d or sorry only
when the vitamin d supplementation is at
a sufficient level that is between 800
and
2000 international units per day
given mainly most of these studies gave
dietary gait calcium supplements as well
so given in combination with calcium do
we see a significant reduction in the
risk of fracture now there are a lot of
data or data from a lot of patients now
which provide the same uh answer so
again here's a study from tang he
published in the lancet in 2007
collecting data from some 52 53 000
patients
if they were given calcium alone or
calcium and vitamin d they were
significant reductions in
the risk of fracture
and and there really what there was no
statistical difference between calcium
and calcium vitamin d in this
meta-analysis
however they did find that the vitamin d
dose had to be greater than 800
international units per day
to achieve a significant reduction in
the fracture
and in the bottom study the dipart group
published in the bmj in 2010
there again 68 000 patients data from 68
000 patients being studied
that if calcium and vitamin d trials
were assessed again there was an eight
percent
reduction in the risk of fracture
statistically significant however
if vitamin d alone was given there was
no effect on the risk of fracture
in these patients
so therefore there is this recognition
that the risk of osteoporotic fractures
increases with serum levels are below
25 20 nanograms per mil
and the current debate and the current
uh
controversy is whether there are any
benefits that can be demonstrated for
serum 25d levels at 30 nanograms per mil
that have not obtained at 50 now or 20
nanograms per mil 15 animals per liter
now there are some data here data
recently published 2013
on the risk of vertebral fractures
with 25d levels and here you can see
that the patients were divided into
those who had 25d levels less than 20 on
the left to those who had 25d levels
greater than 30 on the right and the
patients were also divided into those
who had an elevated pth or had a normal
or suppressed pth
and you can see that those patients who
had the elevated pth and values of 25d
less than 30 had an increased risk of
vertebral fractures
now these are in women who are just 53
to 70 years of age and therefore they
are younger women than to have been
included in the previous trials and so
these are very interesting data to
suggest that an adequate vitamin d
status is required in order to reduce
the risk of fractures even in
middle aged
now these clinical trials particularly
the fracture trials have also been used
to study the effects of vitamin d
supplementation and calcium
supplementation
on the risk of falling and here are data
from a meta-analysis demonstrating that
adequate doses of vitamin d 700 to a
thousand international units per day
compared to lower doses of vitamin d
are necessary to reduce the risk of
falls in subjects living both in
institutions and in the community but
this is with a group who are
significantly older we might call these
an elderly group
and then finally and most importantly
perhaps is
vitamin d supplementation reduces the
risk of premature mortality in frail
elderly subjects so here a forest is a
forest plot from 18 randomized
controlled trials
demonstrating that
at the through the period of this trial
the the subjects who receive the active
ingredient the vitamin d and
calcium supplementation in most of these
trials they had reduced number of deaths
compared to the subjects who were
included in the placebo group and so of
course that's a very important endpoint
and and the cut-off level between
these who had the reduced mortality
during the trial that's why i call it
reduced premature mortality i'm sure
each one of these subjects died in the
end
then so they had reduced premature
mortality was achieved with levels of
around about 31 nanograms per mill for
25 hydroxyd compared to those who died
at a levels about 15 nanograms per
million
so therefore there is some evidence that
the there are benefits at levels of 30
nanograms per mil compared to 20
nanograms per mil but at this stage
we're still collecting those evidence
and we're still fighting a lot of uh
skepticism amongst our clinical
colleagues that these benefits are real
so why would we need different critical
levels for different diseases so in
osteomalacia we can avoid osteomalacia
by having a serum 25d level greater than
about eight nanograms per mill whereas
to avoid reducing the risk of
osteoporotic fractures we need a level
of 25 hydroxyd greater than 20 nanograms
per mil
well as i've decided previously showed
you in this metabolic pathway for
vitamin d in its activity
the kidney synthesizes a plasma 125 d
and where that's in the kidney
um and and and produces endocrine
activity
but also there is an auto paracrine
activity from 25d
whereas there is um the levels are of
where the 25d is converted to 125d
within a cell and we know this occurs in
bone cells it occurs in macrophages and
it occurs in skin cells and in brain
cells in a number of various tissues
so therefore our biomarker is a
substrate for an enzymatic reaction it's
not a a a
a reaction it's not a biologically
active substance in its own right
um the product of any enzyme reaction is
dependent on the level of the substrate
and the level of the enzyme and so
we have these two factors which can
determine the product
now we know that in the kidney it is
very capable under particular conditions
particularly as shown here vitamin d
depletion and a low dietary calcium to
induce the expression of the sip 27 b1g
by some 500 fold
whereas no other tissues have been shown
to be able to induce the enzyme to the
level that the kidney has done
and we can see that other certain
circumstances this is this these this
histogram shows the level of sit 27 b1
activity in a range of tissues and under
conditions of adequate calcium the
kidney is not the highest level other
tissues have higher levels but under
certain circumstances of hypocalcemia
and a low vitamin d status high pgh then
the kidney is capable of up regulating
that
expression to a very high level and so
therefore the um the questions of the
ability we would need less substrate
with a high level of
sip 27 b1 enzyme in the kidney to
continue making adequate 125 d then we
would need bone cells where they do not
have such a high level of the enzyme
under those conditions and therefore we
need to maintain a higher substrate for
the sip 27 b1 in these other tissues
so in the wider health context it's
likely that the physiology of vitamin d
and non-renal tissues operates through
similar activities as that for the bone
cells with local synthesis occur
it's probable that the local synthesis
of 125 d in non-renal tissues may
require different critical levels of
serum 25 d for optimal health outcomes
depending on the level of the enzyme 627
v1 in those tissues
the current trial data indicate that
levels around 30 nanograms per mill can
reduce the risk of falls and premature
mortality
but this controversy around recommending
a critical level of 25 d at 30 nanograms
per mil largely arises from a lack of
strong evidence and further evidence
is required to provide such uh
convincing to all of our
colleagues in the healthcare industry
however i think as as analysts and
providing a service a clinical service
we must also think about the
issues of of the nature of our assays
and so while we recognize that a level
of 25d level of 16 to 20 nanograms per
mill
is greater than 20 nanograms of oil is
required to reduce the risk of fractures
we have to think can we detect
confidently the difference between say a
level of 16 nanograms per ml and 20
nanograms per mil
we would we've shown or we have data to
indicate that there is um a significant
difference in the risk of fracture
between those levels
and the other question of course we have
to consider is whether we would be doing
harm by recommending patients have
levels of some 30 nanograms per mill
now in my view we cannot confidently
detect the difference between 16 and 20
nanograms per mill so therefore for i
believe the we need a cutoff point which
is higher than the 20 nanograms per mill
because there'll be errors around that
and some patients at which we would say
would be 20 or 21 nanograms per mill
might actually be at levels of 18
nanograms per mil and that might be
clinically important
the other question is are we doing harm
by recommending higher levels and i
think that the data certainly are clear
that there is no harm at levels around
30 nanograms per mill very large numbers
of the population had such levels
through their exposure to sunlight and
through their own lifestyle activities
certainly there are toxic levels and
those toxic levels we are unsure of the
lower limits of that and again that is a
subject of great controversy so levels
of
760 or 70 or 80 nanograms per mil there
may be some evidence of toxicity even at
those levels but certainly levels of 100
nanograms per mil would be there would
be evidence of an increased risk of
toxicity
so i finished there and thank you very
much for your attention and very happy
to
have any questions that you might have
put forward and entered
i'll try and look at those now
okay so we have a question uh from
someone that says does it make clinical
sense to report 25 hydroxy d3 and 25
hydroxy d2 separately
no i don't believe it is it's the total
25 hydroxy d
that you want that the clinician and the
patient is interested in
um
and it's uh it's a question of
of providing that
there might be some issue at some stage
whether to ask or to provide an answer
as to whether there is a problem or
whether the patient is taking a d2
supplement or not but that is not what
um is of great interest uh it's really
the total 25 hydroxy d that is required
and currently this is not possible at uh
by immunoassays this is only possible by
a
by a chromatographic method whether it
be hplc or uh or liquid chromatogens in
liquid chromatography
now have a
second
question from
christine in elizabethtown college and
she asked in clinical studies have there
been any correlations between levels of
stress
and vitamin d levels now that's a very
interesting question
they're hazarding
there was a nobel prize awarded to a
scientist elizabeth blackburn who
discovered that uh
the stress and the or the longevity of
cells was determined by their telomere
length by the length of this section of
chromatin called the telomeres
and
they have done assays now
demonstrating in both patients and in
experimental models that the telomere
leaf as stress increases telomere length
decreases and therefore longevity
decreases and in fact in
disease chronic diseases such as
diabetes they've been able to
demonstrate that telomere length is
decreased in patients who have diabetes
etc now there's been a recent study
demonstrating that 25 higher 25 hydroxy
vitamin d levels are associated with
increased telomere length
and therefore there may be from this
study one might say well are these
people um
is there an effect
of longevity or increasing our telomeres
which is associated with uh
providing us with a longer a longer
lifespan so the issues of stress is it's
an experimental area it's an area of
interest certainly um and that of course
one could also imagine this is the whole
issue with um vitamin d status and
the question of uh of of association
with other diseases is that is it a
biomarker of a healthy lifestyle is it a
biomarker that the person who goes out
and is doing exercise walking and who
will therefore get more uvb exposure
will they will therefore have a higher
serum 25d level whereas the is it and
the person who is sick
staying inside will have a lower 25d so
that would be just associations and not
necessarily a causal link and so that's
the key issue the key
uh
question about whether the
the issues of stress and longevity and
the wider health benefits of
vitamin d are they
are they overblown are they are they
exaggerated because all it is is a
marker of a of a healthy lifestyle now
of course to have a healthy lifestyle
might be in you know might be good might
be worthwhile having um but you probably
don't need a serum measurement of 25d to
tell you that you've got a healthy
lifestyle that you go out walking
probably other
just asking questions might tell you
that
okay well that seems to be all the
questions so i think we can finish off
there and i thank you for your interest
and uh and and your attention thank you
very much